外国
[音乐]
大家好，欢迎大家
这是actinf 直播号 47.0
现在是 2022 年 8 月 3 日
欢迎来到主动推理
学院
我们是一个参与式在线实验室和
学院，交流学习
和实践应用主动推理
你可以 在幻灯片上的一些链接中找到我们
这是一个录制的、存档的、
转录的和现场发布的，
所以请向我们提供反馈，
以便我们改进我们的工作
欢迎所有背景和观点，我们将遵循
现场视频礼仪 流
所有活跃的推理研究所
活动都是参与性的，所以
如果您想贡献或参与，请告诉我们
，请访问 activeinference.org 并单击链接
直接参与并了解
更多信息，
我们即将开始
奇数
和 47 年的独特冒险。
我们
将不会像往常一样讨论和并列一篇论文，
而是要多开眼界
对于在这种情况下的两篇论文，
我们
将以并列的方式学习和讨论 ati vaiko pieteren 和 majid beni
在 2021 年的两篇论文主动推理和绑架，
我们还将讨论ines 的主动
动态社会认知和主动
推理 hippolyto 和 thomas
van s 也从 2021 年开始，
所有视频都
点零，否则
是对这些想法和
附加上下文的介绍，而不是评论或
评估或最终决定
，我们将
始终如一地希望将这种
浅红色的颜色用于绑架纸
和 浅蓝色代表不
活跃的空间，为新的颜色
和组合打开空间，
展示一些综合
领域 这
与许多实时流有点不同，
然后我们将根据目标和声明的 roa
提供每篇论文的概述信息
dmap
和摘要
，然后我们将转到
上下文部分的背景部分
，其中将包含大量
关于不作为符号学溯因逻辑的信息等
，
然后我们将进入
两篇论文的并列
，我们将有一个 在即将到来的
讨论中，希望有很多时间与多位作者
进行
讨论。1.2 甚至更多，所以
今天我们想带来一个大
背景，
讨论一些非常有趣的线程，
提供一些背景知识，
帮助人们进入这个领域，然后
提供 最初的并列并
浏览这些论文，
这会让人们兴奋地阅读这些
论文更深入地深入研究并
带来他们自己的观点来处理这些
非常有趣的话题，
所以
我们将转向介绍
我是丹尼尔，我是 加利福尼亚的一位研究人员
，我将
在接下来的幻灯片中更多地谈论令人兴奋的事情我会把它传递给
院长
呃早上好我的名字是院长我在
卡尔加里，呃我想我
可能是 扭曲的思想试图
将这个想法放在一起，并可能
通过尝试提取
看似
不同的民间焦点的两篇不同的论文来改变我们看待主动推理的方式
，然后
这两篇论文也都
结合了主动推理的使用
作为一种
情境分析的方法，
这意味着什么，
所以我觉得这真的很令人兴奋
，我会把它交给
斯蒂芬，谢谢院长，是的，斯蒂芬在这里，我
在加拿大多伦多嗯
，我在
对这两篇论文都非常感兴趣，
因为
它们都谈到了一般的
参与式
方法
以及人们如何参与世界的想法，
嗯，所以围绕
嗯不作为
的问题真的很相关，
绑架片也是如此，
嗯
虽然它们都是完全不同的
论文，但它们都
非常强烈地对我说话，所以这真的很
有趣，所以我期待能够
探索我 我正在与
呃参与式剧院
社区心理学社区
发展和多尺度
发展过程一起工作，我真的很
高兴看到
这种科学观点如何
能够满足
更多可能被称为基于实践的
参与性问题，我 '一直在
看所以我会把它传给
丹尼尔
非常感谢你们和院长再次感谢我们
经历
了许多个月的旅程我们走过的许多电子邮件和月度
和消息之旅
因为我确实希望这会
展开并包括在 一种
采用实时流媒体
和我们正在处理的材料的
方式超出了我们已经完成的工作
，
本着这种精神，如果您要拉两个，我将通过院长
介绍一些大问题
就主题而言似乎没有太多共同点的论文，
您将不得不
从
不同的角度来研究它，不仅
要找出论文中的内容，而且
如何比较这些论文，
所以我们
围绕以下
想法收集了一些问题
问题基本上是
主动推理既
可以是持有或包含或
限制某物的东西，也可以是被
限制或被抓住的东西什么是主动
推理，或者如果主动强调
这两个被包含的东西
嗯说表格中的分区线
和 一个单元格，
以便我们
实际上可以将更多信息放入
看起来像它
同时作为约束和分隔符的实际差距，
我认为这
是我们要
尝试梳理的相互关系 接下来的几个
直播以及在掌握模型方面的相似或不同之处
以及建模的不同过程
谢谢史蒂文 t 在
这里添加任何东西
不 我认为
这涵盖了很多 唯一的
那个 x 是有某种
表示
你知道可以主动推理模型
建模
um 框架所以这就是
这个术语的上下文化
玩，但我们
稍后再谈，所以是的，谢谢
太棒了，
这
可能是我们的第一个目标
幻灯片之一，
因为希望它有助于
回到这个水平
，这里的模因
代表这个现场直播
汇集
这两篇论文以一种我们曾经用
一只手拍手的方式
现在我们将把它们
合二为一你已经可以听到来自现场直播的声音，
特别是如果
你正在听
院长你会如何描述
拉姆斯 或者你会如何
总结哦，我要
补充的关于 rna ames 的另一条注释是我们希望它是
全面的，但也
有可听且具有合理
时间持续时间的视频，所以会有很多
滑动 es 会
从纸上复制大量文本，
如果您想阅读，只需注意暂停视频，
但我们将继续
从我们
真正想要确保的许多文本幻灯片 所有的
文字都在那里看不见，但我们
不会阅读所有内容，所以
请院长，嗯，总结一下
你想谈论的这些目标中的哪一个，
你知道我只是要
谈谈
每个目标的根源 这些子弹
之一是仔细研究
现实主义乐器工具主义
辩论我不必深入探讨那
是什么如果你曾经参与过它
你知道我们在描述什么
呃加强两只眼睛睁开的方法
一只眼睛在这对
主动推理论文中看到不活跃的
动态社会状况
和绑架，而
另一只眼睛如果另一只眼睛表现出主动推理
作为两者的整合者，
因为我们认为它实际上可以做到
这一点而无需混合
它实际上会导致 编织或 辫子
，然后第三个要点是
明确说明绝对必要性，如果我们
要做前两件事，即
理解模型的时间深度，
当我们对两个不同的主题进行主动推理时，实际上会合并两篇看似遥远的主题的论文，
并且 那么我们所做的只是提取
了作者在他们的论文中提到的不同的东西，
谢谢你和斯蒂芬，如果你能
在这些目标之间继续阅读，
或者从这张幻灯片中添加任何你想要的东西，
是的，谢谢丹尼尔，所以
你知道一个 一组作者说你
知道真的在看
工具
主义，你知道你知道这是一个有效的
科学观点，但你知道
那里有然后描述你知道
这个关于通往
现实主义
和正常主义道路的问题，所以
你知道
这个想法在哪里
工具主义的一篇论文
是一种
捕捉或
让自己在这项科学工作中保持
良好状态的方法，它可以 受到挑战
，我们会看到我们
可能
需要放松的方式，当我们进入
参与式方法时，
介于两者之间的东西会放松科学
空间并且是实践空间，所以
与第二点相同，
嗯
，好的是 工具
主义 嗯，你知道前进的方向，那么什么构成了生活在利基中的行为 什么
构成了生物
嗯，我们如何
解决前进的方向 如果
存在矛盾，
如果我们在一个
团队中试图调和它们 使用这个
嗯，我们应该和他们一起生活，
然后继续前进，
或者我们应该在哪里真正突出
它们，所以这在某种程度上试图
在一个嗯之外思考，也许这种
激光
关注科学
哲学点，然后说好的
我们正在尝试将这些带入团队
环境中，
如果我们可以放松其中的一些
，那么这里只是提到
提供一个应用程序，如果我们也
认为 关于
主动印记的前缀或
后缀您知道自适应主动
影响有效的主动影响或
主动推理建模
您知道澄清是多么重要
然后
还要考虑如何
以这些其他方式利用工具主义现实主义作品
我们需要定位 嗯，
你完全了解另一个
，如果我们介于两者之间，
你知道
是否可以根据上下文或多或少地获得
知识，所以经常在
参与性工作中
不同类型的实践，你
知道上下文是关键
，然后是这种 of
谈到了我自己对共同创作
工作的看法，我知道，嗯，
你知道丹尼尔非常喜欢团队
和
院长，非常喜欢转型你
知道经常有一个共同创作的
作品有一个你的地方
你想在不压碎蝴蝶的情况下支撑蝴蝶
那里有一些
非常微妙的东西
所以我们有时怎么
能把它带到它所在的
空间 o-创意空间，你知道在哪里
以更微妙的
上下文方式进行建模
，
虽然我们有这些
科学定义、战略
设计和硬分析
，它们很有用，但我们不希望它们
破坏正在发生的事情
，还有一些 那里的图片
可以说明这一点，我可能会把它
交给院长，你可以谈谈
两者之间的水样和头脑中的
差距，
我认为我认为
这是一个很好的解释，我
认为
如果和 当作者
能够上场时，
我们现在就可以给它添加一些颜色了
可以在那些不同的节点之间移动，
这就是我认为我们想要在
这里建立的
中间性，
就像它说的那样，注意间隙是
唯一可以在地铁上杀死你的东西，
因为你没有
注意 嘎 p 和我认为
之间的水域采样
做同样的事情，除了它在这些间隙的流动性方面提供了
一点不同的
细微差异，
所以我
认为
如果我们使用它作为我们的门户会非常有趣 了解
我们如何把东西放在一起，
让他们
跳舞，否则他们会
坐在房间另一边的椅子上，
这可能是一个有趣的
谈话，从第一点和第二点开始，
谢谢你们，我唯一的评论
添加这里是
我们一直在讨论的
形容词，这些形容词
以自适应情感等主动
推理
为前缀，然后还进一步强调了您对 x 和
括号
主动推理模型作为一个实例
或案例或实现
主动推理的后缀的关注 框架主动
推理过程理论接下来会发生什么
，这真的让我想起了语法和句法中的
左分支和右分支
子句，
并且有一个基础 c  lause
什么是我们的基本条款，然后是什么
之前的分支和之后的分支，我认为
有一个非常丰富的空间，我真的很
喜欢这些具体的
和基于通量的隐喻，它们帮助我们非常
了解嗯
，所以
在论文概述中
这将只是一些元数据和
在我们回到背景背景之前对论文的描述
，然后继续讨论
论文的主要观点，
所以我们不会阅读摘要
它们当然都适用于这些论文
这里是摘要 主动
推理和诱因
这里是非
主动动态社会认知和主动推理的摘要
这里是这
两篇论文的关键词 非主动论文
有关键词 社会认知生态位
构建
主动推理理论和
行动主义和动力系统
理论 诱拐论文有 关键词
绑架 主动推理 自由能
原理 第一和毯子
三元关系和刺穿
让我们看看绑架论文的目的
和主张，
所以
院长你想涵盖
绑架论文的任何目标
吗？我想做的只是
预测
两篇论文的目标是
什么 你会在
这篇文章的第二个项目符号中看到一个
关键词，那就是联盟，然后
你会在另一篇论文中看到一些词，
他们再次说
我们希望事情走到一起，
但我们想要 小心我们如何
描述走到一起，我们不
希望它被比喻
为混合，作为
我们认为
具有
关联关系的两个或更多事物的撤消，所以我认为当
你经历 这两篇
论文的目标如果你
稍微退后一点，你会发现
两篇论文的作者都
在对
他们希望我们关注的关系进行艰难的解释，所以
这就是他们俩的事情 论文
分享这是一个沉重的emph 关于
关系的
重要观点，它们都写得非常
丰富和有力
，在这里我们看到联盟和忠诚
，当然
在这两篇论文中都会有很多关于
整合不同或部分
相关的本体和词汇集
以及不同思想家不同线程的讨论
关于智力发展的
这些引文可以阅读，当然也可以在论文中进行
扩展，
但正如 Dean 所说，本文的重点是
主动推理和自由能
原理 fep 之间的智力联盟，主要是
cs pierce
在以下方面的工作 符号学 语用学
语法学 溯因逻辑，即
目标综合
，以一种协同的方式将这两者结合在一起，
并提供意义，
斯蒂芬是的，只是按照
你所说的这两篇论文，
特别是它给出的溯因论
看看那些真的很难
用计算机模拟的领域
绑架发生的方式，
特别是人类的绑架方式
非常复杂，我认为
看到符号学真的很有帮助，
它实际上
在
戏剧超声和布景设计中
被
大量使用
这就是你知道的超越
科学通常是正确的，它经常用于
其他领域，
例如自然科学有一些用处，
但它经常用于人文学科，所以
我认为
这是在与那篇文章谈论
它所
揭示的那种秘密酱汁
这种对灵魂的打击通常是
缺失的，并且在行动
中也有一些东西，就像
这篇论文的令人敬畏的声明
贯穿了整个论文，但只是为了
强调他们声称的一些关键声明，
他们声称他们的目标是
在主动推理的工作
和绑架和符号学观点之间做出选择，
他们似乎声称这是
可行的，并且他们提供了一个
初始的
在这个新旧东西的理论理论
整合
中勾勒出
一些红色的东西蓝色的东西
新旧的东西，
新旧两个框架
分别
是
神经科学和认知科学的现代实例，
以自由能原理为代表
，在 旧的
对溯因推理的历史准确和精确的解释，
包括
研究经济的重要性所有
我们将要回来的东西只是
想澄清那里的主张我可以
添加一个是的，请
真正快速所以理论整合
在那里我 如果你能
回想一下我们现在谈论我们的
目标时
的意思，问题是这就是
作者所说
的话 想要我想
回溯一下那一步，因为我
认为当我们看的时候这种情况会再次发生
在另一篇论文中，
他们将使用不同的命名法，但
他们会说同样的话，
而且很难看到共同点，
除非你不需要编造
它们，
你只需要
在 两种不同类型的森林，
并指出它们
都在某种程度上使用主动推理
作为积分器和
微分器我们正在通过区分它们然后当然是集成来制作
内部和
外部和全面状态的
集成模型 和微分
在数学中也有积分
和导数表示法的共同用法，所以
会有很多事情走到
一起，嗯，
史蒂文你的手还在，是的，
是的，只有一件事我认为
这真的很有帮助
计算神经科学中的
神经科学，并强调这一点，
因为我认为
这
是世界上的现实，
那里的文化
，这些想法所在的地方 循环的是
，神经科学
基本上是通过
积极影响
神经科学作为一个领域
而转变的，正如人们所理解的那样，它
是
某种
事物进入然后
被评估和
具体化的演绎过程，而不是这种
预测之旅，所以我认为它
真的非常有用
因为这是
我们所有人都面临的事情，我想当我
与一些神经科学家交谈时我也注意到的
是，他们实际上已经经历
了一场生存危机，并且
经常通过提出不活跃的
主张并看看是否真的发生了转变 不活跃的
说法是如何将他们与神经科学的工作
如此结合在一起的，所以
这里有一篇
与
一般性有关的
文章，
当我们开始
从专业领域带来积极影响时，一般性的文章更重要
它是一种
飞地，它的游戏规则是
众所周知的，你进入了
人们说神经科学很好的领域 我知道
这意味着什么
，你走了，非常感谢，非常感谢
，这篇论文的章节相对较少，
它有一个介绍
，然后
根据主动推理提出了一对主动
推理，根据主动
推理
略微倾斜地提及任何内容
生物学是有意义的，
除非从进化的角度或从某些东西的角度来看
，这是
回到那个岛屿的两盏灯，它们之间的空间是什么
，然后讨论
了研究经济及其自由
能自然化，以及结论
和 穿孔兔子洞很深，
我们将
很快进入非活动论文的一些内容，
所以在这里我们将描述
非活动
动态社会认知和主动
推理论文
的 ames 声明和路线图，该论文提出了两个-  fold
旨在剖析
将激进主义与推理性叙述相结合的新叙述，
并解释为什么这样做会引起
矛盾
是首要目标
，其次是 cond 的目标是
提供唯一合理的帐户链接，
尤其是在这种社会认知案例中，
所以
是的，请不要猜我
希望你现在可以为我们把链接这个词变成
紫色
是的，
谢谢你
我们有不同的方式 描述
了斯蒂芬
在我们真正开始看论文之前做了一个很好的强调工作
是的，它介于两者之间，是的，
它很棒，它实际上是
通过你的请求和幻灯片
平台，它变成了一个活跃的动态
社会耻辱
等等
这是对什么的概念证明，
但这是本文的目的
和假设
有什么样的逻辑关系，
嗯，
他们将提出
关于认知的本质及其
他们将讨论
与人类社会认知利基相关的一些主张，
并讨论
关系文化适应利基
构建的重要性
，然后他们将
讨论心智理论
以及相容性或
矛盾性
与将
不活跃的
主张与
心智理论或推理帐户联系起来，
该论文的
路线图
非常清楚地
列出了其中许多目标和主张
ttom
和他们正如他们所说的那样，剖析了这个
描述
，试图梳理出
他们
认为非活动计数和推理
计数结合在一起的方式
他们的论文
第 2 节必须给出一些东西来
拒绝不活跃的推理 通过
其他人的想法，
他们将利用两个假设，
即社会认知减少为
心理表征，以及两个
社会认知从出生就与生俱来
，他们将不同意这
两个假设，并
反对
由子声明支持的这些假设 以及
将引导他们
得出更广泛结论的证据，
他们将使用动力系统
理论，
并讨论 dst
如何在兼容性方面与激进主义联系起来，
以及这两个
框架在
工具主义阅读中相互提供什么
， 然后他们将一方面
在动力系统理论的背景下专门讨论主动推理，
另一方面在
非主动
认知社会认知的背景下讨论非主动
动态
连字符，
他们将用一些
关于
社会不作为之间的异同的数字来描述
在主动推理之外进行概念化
，然后它们是 将在
视觉上介绍主动推理如何
丰富该图片
，然后他们有一个非常有趣的
表格来区分
自然界中观察到的现象
和自然界中观察到的行为
上下文
部分的背景，所以在点零的这一部分，
我们肯定会
使用论文中的一些引用，
但我们也会退后一步
，展示
奖学金和研究的冰山一角
我们在此之前所做的工作
希望能
激发听众或读者的兴趣，
并为这些
将在论文中接近和近似的非常深入的线程提供一些背景信息，
我将在此处提供第一个注释或院长
请去
只是我想我认为这是一个
壮观的时刻，可以说
好的，所以
背景和背景，所以我们谈论的
可能
是时间和物理
环境，
所以 现在我们可以根据
情况
进行分析了 方法和和
我会想象这些
方法
中的每一种都有或多或少的可行性
取决于
时间和物理上的情况，
所以我认为
这是关键的事情，我们并不是
说这些论文
中的每一篇都是好还是坏
我们说这些论文中的每
一篇都关注至少两个不同的
背景上下文组合
，所以现在如果我们将这两件事
放在一起，我们不能
说这将是我们要做的同一
件事
提出我们的目标，因为人们现在
并排看了两篇论文，
这将创建一个全新的
实体，
谢谢
你带领这个背景和
背景 tualizing 部分我想
引用我最喜欢的工匠诗人
威廉布莱克
和布莱克写的
相反是积极的否定
不是相反的
否定不是相反的相反
相互存在
但否定不存在不存在
例外和反对和不信不
存在也不应该被
组织起来
在这个布莱克式的
四重逻辑框架
中，永远永远的引用相反实际上
是辩证法的一部分，它们
作为彼此的函数而存在，就像凸面
和凹面一样，或者像
巴克敏斯特·富勒（buckminster fuller）可能会
采取的重力
和辐射一样，因此在这个诗意的否定中
框架
是那些
不存在的，
而 a 和 b 可以相反，
而 a 和 not a 具有不同的
逻辑关系，这种
识别状态空间和
真理的四重逻辑方法声称多个并列的
断言可以与
在许多世界
知识传统中也
预示着彼此之间 例如，kata scotty
，这是一种合乎逻辑的
工具和方法，已经在印度语境
的佛法传统中应用了很长时间
，并且希望
提供这些图像，
欢迎你们中的任何一个来探索
什么 一只手拍手或一个人
做分裂
是否与矛盾和
否定
有关，是的，院长是的，关于矛盾也是如此，我
认为这
指向
了上下文片段的类型，
嗯，情景
分析片段
是
有里面的情况
如果这有意义的
话，就会构建矛盾，
而且这也体现
在我们的生活中，所以很可能
作为一个婴儿，我们知道
孩子在
不同
阶段在不同背景下的形态，提供了建立情境的
方法
意识
和其中的矛盾
随着事情的编纂所以你有
这些这些
这些情况
嗯
过程有点像我们
在这个正在进行的建模流程中正在做的事情
这些不同论文中支持
它们的实践领域的类型不活跃者感觉是一种实践，
或者嗯，他们拥有更多的计算
实践领域他们是 我们所
体现的，我们进入的，我们学习的
，这就是我们
直觉地建模的方式，我们
感觉到我们应该如何建模
在这些情况下的矛盾，
但是
经常建模，这是危险的
时候 它被
具有模型的人所压倒，
即
某人在他们的世界中塑造
自己的感觉或试图
处理它
会告诉我们
他们的问题是它是如何构建的，所以
我认为这个模型模型在
这里非常相关，因为你知道
一旦这些矛盾
建立起来，很可能
会有一个模型 del 在该域中创建
，然后不一定
在该域中的人
可以归因于模型，他们不
知道游戏是什么，他们不在
过程中并且模型接管，以便
切换到拆分
因为那好吧，我们有两件事
他们在一起
我们正在谈论这个是的，让
你敞开心扉，你有一个立场，
好吧，所以我有点，在某些时候
它就像那不是一个立场兄弟
那是 这是一个分裂，你已经进入了
那里，你必须要小心，
所以你已经进入了这个想法，
你现在正在打开一些东西，如果它们是
一开始的，
如果它们是他们被持有的立场 在某些
方面，他们是否以某种方式分裂，
现在他们
彼此孤立，你知道我
想我们正试图找到一种
方法，既不把他们推到一个
也不分裂，也许
在这两者之间
有一个立场 嗯，在某种程度上是敏捷的吗？
在这种情况下，它与现实主义和
ins 相关 trumentalism 这与一些
更广泛的主题相呼应
谢谢院长
，真的很快
例如，联合概率上升了很多
，所以这里的分裂的想法
是一个非常好的比喻，
因为
如果你正在
看有主动
干扰的东西，你假设
在一个茶迷宫实验中你必须
向左或向右走好 人类
可以看到一个岔路口并采取它
这是一种常设笑话
如果你看到我腿上的一个岔路口采取他们
不一定
你必须选择一个orbee你可以
采取整个事情而且我认为这就是
布莱克 试图用这个
练习指出一个矛盾，
如果我在路上看到器物我可以
接受它，但如果我不
接受叉子不仅意味着左或右的想法，
那么我就是 在 wh 方面已经自我限制
在我正在测试我的
情景分析时，
谢谢你们两个都可以进入更
直接的关键字片段，
所以在 thisdefinitions.net
网站的行动中，行动是组织知识的可能方式之一，也是
与世界非活动知识互动的形式之一
是通过行动获得的知识，并建立
在运动技能之上，例如操纵
物体骑自行车或参加一项
运动，这只是提供的众多
定义
之一
例如
，在 2020 年的第 6 期活动直播
中，我们完全讨论
了 ramstead 两个密度的故事
主动推理是 2021 年的积极推理
，
我们还讨论了 hippolyto 的一篇论文，
它完全体现
了动作所在的熟练表演
，有趣
的是 在某些方面，这个讨论非常重要，
这是
来自现场直播的幻灯片，嗯
，嗯，嘻哈纸
和 在这里，我们有刺耳的
呃三元组，我们有象征意义，
这个符号学和对法语的引用，
所以我们实际上是在谈论
非常相关的表示概念
，实际上是那些支持
和/或拒绝或发现矛盾
和联系的人
以上关于
不作为和推理帐户
的讨论将在很大程度上取决于
表征和认知
表征的问题，它们在哪里或
是否存在等等，
嗯，
这是现场直播 23. 同样来自 sangati 的这篇论文，
呃，他们 仅在视觉上进行布局，我们
很快就会
在他们的观点中看到更多的表示，
一些
传统社会认知
和非活动社会认知之间的区别
，因此，不仅仅是
对图像名称的视觉解释，
你想提供它
不，我等着 你在下一个好，
所以在这里我看到的是，在
传统的社会认知推理
账户中
，齿轮 在大脑内部转动
，然后有感知动作循环
和联系，
将他们体内的社会实体联系起来，但
身体被视为
这种信息的界面，传递
一种极端的姿态或简单的视觉
表现
，然后在这里相反，我们
看到齿轮无处不在
，包括在环境中的利基之间的
空间
，是的，大脑正在做事，
但它也是一个已实施系统的一部分，它
在整体框架中更多地实施这种培养的社会认知过程，所以 院长 是的
是的 我只是想马上
说我们要
看看绑架的事情但是
现在
我希望人们只是
在他们的脑海中保持这样的想法
这是对一种类型的说话 时间
深度，但时间深度是
垂直的
国王时间深度，但
重点是垂直或深度
时间深度，而不是宽横向
时间深度
它们都很重要，但它们是正交的
，并不意味着它们相互冲突
，它只是意味着它们正在
前进 在不同的方向上，这就是
我想说
的，有趣的是左右或西方和
东方那些是相反的方向，但
它们不是否定的方向，
所以我们开始
看到正交性、稀疏性或条件独立性是如何
授予的 例如，通过马尔可夫毯子，
如何在相反的框架中看到这些
，而不是否定的
斯蒂芬
和右手
图中的齿轮在那里，
你知道之间的齿轮可以有时间深度
，可以有这个身心
就像你说的那样，环境片段肯定在那里
，显然作为一个分析单元，
这真的很有挑战性，我
也会把它放在那里作为齿轮词
词
抽搐
t 我们的语音盒的巫术在我们
周围的空间中给了我们文字，
所以你知道它们也被用作
工具所以突然间
我们更加陷入困境，即使它
只是演讲，
是的，演讲需要时间才能
穿越 互联网，并通过
时空
更深入地了解社会
不作为
这个呃不作为研究资源
描述了表演中
不作为的几种含义
和
感觉，所以请阅读de bruyne
在认知符号学中的一篇非常好的2009年论文
和德哈恩
讨论了
行动主义在社会认知中的一些关系
，他们出色地
总结了推理
和非行动主义账户可以
汇集的内容，并
讨论了这种联系
如果他们要使用桥梁比喻，这是一件有趣的事情，
我认为激进主义确实有桥梁，
它只是一座垂直的桥梁，
它是 建筑物的一侧正在上升
，所以
没有什么不是为了不批评
他们在这里写的东西，但我认为
有债务
并且有能力跨越它
只是它是
垂直的它不是传统
上并排的
太棒了
所以 对
绑架和符号学有一点深入了解，
我们一起经历了一段相当长的学习之旅
，
绑架论文
有
一个或一个半甚至两个
作者是真正的皮尔逊专家，
提供了许多细节
皮尔斯是一位多产的作家和思想家
和合作者，还有很多
工作都没有发表，这意味着
有一些神秘的参考系统
，并不是所有的都是超级可访问的，
我们发现 commons.org 网站
在提供许多
定义以及资源链接方面非常有用。
你喜欢
在这个页面上总结任何东西，
如果你对
实用主义感兴趣并且你想超越
威廉詹姆斯实际上是威廉 詹姆斯和
查尔斯·桑德斯·皮尔斯有一点点，
他们可能是 150 年前
围绕
事情如何运作的第
一个冲突者 彼此
更聪明，但事实上很多
事情很多我们 150 年
后现在回顾的想法，我们
不得不说他们可能觉得他们在
相互竞争，但我认为
他们所做的是在传递 或者
以某种方式建立一个更好的模型，因为
他们并不总是
通过睁着双眼的同一只眼睛看待事物，
所以我只想说
去公共站点，这真的很好，
是的，很棒，这个表示
具有讽刺意味的是适当地削减
是著名的
皮尔逊三合会符号学框架，其中一个
停止标志被称为代表
所代表的
实例 物理停止标志 真正的
停止
标志 对象是一团糟 老车必须停
在这里，解释是我应该
停在这里，这就是我们得到那个
实体机构的地方
我发现了一篇关于用户界面的有趣论文
，它将一些
关于符号学和逻辑的真正永恒的讨论
带入了他们正在应用的数字环境
用户界面隐喻
的符号化可以想象，如果这是
现实世界中的一个停车标志，或者它是
用户界面上下文中网站上的一个按钮，那么
任何人都可以暂停并阅读其中一些
非常优秀的引用
和呃选择
这里有很多关于复制符号和符号如何通过逻辑和符号学联系起来的讲座，但我们将继续
专门讨论绑架，所以这
有点关于穿孔和
符号学的定义，而不是
事物的科学，更积极的
科学 和形式科学这
是更正式的科学
什么是溯因推理
这是非常令人着迷的探索
这是引述 在
他们写的论文中，这在二手文献中很常见，
例如，在 pierce 的基础上将
绑架设想为发生在
两个部分或两种
生成性绑架和选择性
绑架
这里是关于这两种
类型或两个品种或两个
组件的二冲程发动机的另一种观点 他们在哲学文献中写
的斯坦福百科全书的绑架
呃哲学
绑架一词在
两种意义上都有两种相关但不同的
含义 该术语指的是
历史上第一种意义上
的解释性推理 它指的是解释性推理在
产生假设中的位置 那是生成性
溯因，而在第二种意义
上，即现代文学中最常使用的意义上，它
指的是解释性
推理在证明或评估一
组列举的假设时的位置
，从某种意义上说，它
使内容有意义 必须产生
才能被策划 想法必须是具体的
列举了为了证明或
评估
院长请继续这口
井，只是真的很快，所以
我们现在有红色和蓝色，这
真的很重要，要
强调你需要两者你至少需要
两个才能让解释
出现
在下一个绑架
概率意义上的推理也被称为
对最佳解释
的推理是一种逻辑推理形式，它着眼
于最可能的假设来解释
某事 例如
左手的白豆是否来自右手拿着的袋子
手在这里，我们
可以看到提出的假设如何
取决于
不完整的观察或
推论 袋子里也有豆子
，即使是这样，
已经转移到左手的东西的来源，
所以
当你到达时再次进入时间深度 一种情况
你拥有什么样的背景和什么样的背景
将进入这第四种
逻辑形式，或者钱包看起来很真实 你
花了一生的时间
试图
解开，然后
重新形成某种连贯性
，
那些倾听的人可能会开始看到
先验感官观察
的暗示，对世界的信念的更新，甚至行动选择开始发挥作用，尤其是将
启示的瞬时行动
可用性转化为
可以通过他们预期的自由能量来评估的政策，
但我们将到达那里，
让我们
转向绑架，这里有一些
非常有趣的论文，这些论文
与绑架相关的公地很多，
并继续其中之一
托马斯·卡潘 (thomas capitan) 的关于作为实践推论的公共资源资源
这部
我们不会阅读所有
内容的工作涉及许多有趣的
观点
，即关于具有假设生成和假设选择的绑架的双重性质，
并区分假设
选择
可以进行演绎 有效的评估，
但创造力阶段 e
是非推理性的，
与类似不预先审查的
想法有很多共鸣，并且
在头脑风暴时进行了包容性的讨论，
并认识到
必须在有限的空间和时间段内进行筛选
此外还有一些讨论
这里是
当我们回到
自由能原理或与自由能原理相互交织时
，对假设的初始认识
来自于
通过
对思想世界的不受控制的洞察力对组合整体的观察，
对他所谓的第三性
在感知中给予
的新奇构想
前提 2
引用论文前一部分的实例是
由先验认知引起的，
其内容是由事实观察感官观察所暗示的，
但并非所有暗示的内容都是
从对事实的认知中推断出来的
，因此
皮尔斯继续描述
存在 在
逻辑上完全类似于
推论，
只接受它们是 unc 有意识的
，因此无法控制，
因此不会受到批评，因此
抛开诸如
无意识过程是否可以被
认为是可控的问题
在这里，我们非常看到
感知的暗示是无意识的推论，
我们还看到
了注意力和意识过程之间的连续性，
有意识的推论
和其他潜意识的推论 所以
在某种程度上，这也提供了一个
感知学习信念的综合框架，
更新时间深度
有意识和无意识意识
所有这些特征都在波斯作品中进行了探索
，绑架
论文将非常具体地
强调这一事实，
可以继续进行一点 更多
呃 绑架和还原
你想在这个院长身上添加什么吗
我的意思是那些研究它并
有时分析这个奇迹的人，无论这是否是
一种
形态，或者我们是否可以
同时使用这两个术语或再次互换使用这两个术语
可能是一个 在那些事情
中，如果你
想知道细节是什么，
你可能应该去看看，
因为它很有趣，但
在这一点上，我们基本上想做的
只是在这里，我只会
阅读 从
令人惊讶的一系列事实中，我们被引导
到一个
推测的过程，我们使用了很多
推测来解释它们，许多
逻辑学家拒绝称之为最后一个
推论，
因为它的结论非常
有问题，以至于比审讯多一点
我敢肯定他们是错的，但是他们
还没有
掌握推理的真正科学
定义，所以他
在这里基本上要说的是，我们不要
将
溯因推理红外线 um
归纳推理
称为推理的逻辑
理由，其正确的
结论是 推测
的事物状态很可能
在模糊的意义上
倾向于类似于事物的真实
状态，这就是其中的
部分 at 取代了
工具
主义无论我们定义为
工具主义，
这又
是一个难题
将它标记
为什么填充什么感觉
最终使整个
问题成为这里的问题
并且再次值得阅读绑架论文
的一位作者之前的一些工作
，人们可以
在他们的研究中看到一条强有力的
发展和 扩展和
现代化很多工作
，
是的，所以我放下那些熊标志，
因为我想讲一个非常非常
非常快速的故事，
所以如果你住在有熊的地方，
如果熊标志一直存在，
人们就会开始忽略 实际的
标志
对象
，他们不再成为翻译
他们故意
失去那个三元组所以
如果你从事
动物
福利业务并且你不希望熊
变得太
习惯于 人联系你必须
非常有选择性，当你贴上标志时
，最重要的是当你移除
标志时，
所以我想把它放在那里，因为
这是绑架和还原部分的重要组成部分，
你有时必须把东西
拿走 绑架工作是消除
可能性实际上
创造了一个重
根据现实主义，这种知识
事实性知识是对宇宙的
一般或特定特征的描述，
因此这并不意味着
重力模型就是重力并不
意味着重力模型
就是重力物体，
而是现实主义者会 请注意，
例如，重力的形式模型告诉
我们存在
受重力作用的物体，
并允许描述一种力
，它可以 不被直接看到听到或
感觉到但仍然具有明显的
影响
力是真实的事物
根据工具
主义是真实的即使是完全正确的理论
也没有描述任何东西，而是
作为预测构成其经验内容的事实的工具
，因此 再次在这个牛顿的
万有引力的例子中，工具主义者
可以采取这样的立场，没有
实体
引力和引力
场仅仅
是统计
论证或可能甚至是社会或
权力动力学
论证的工具应用，工具主义者可能会
否认物体
实体和力的存在 案例
，甚至
对作为
工具的单词和围绕交流的关系
以及它如何排序和预测感觉
数据持怀疑态度
我们已经在流中探索了很多现实主义和工具主义
，我们在梅尔
安德鲁斯的作品中强调了很多 在直播号码 14.
再来一张关于现实主义和工具主义的幻灯片，然后你们中的任何一个都
请随意，
嗯，
我将再次描述一些底部的
地图，地图领域的区别是
现实主义和工具主义对话的关键，
还有各种优秀的
哲学
著作 例如，现实主义
反现实主义问题的继承
者，顺便说一句，这两个是
否定的，而我们建议的现实主义和工具主义
可能被视为
相反
，海伦·隆加诺关于科学多元化的工作也有很多话
要说，通过采取
关于现实主义和工具主义的多学科视角
，然后是院长，你想描述
一下你发现的这篇顶级论文吗？
我能不记得在
宏伟计划中这个老实说它在这里供
人们阅读有很多论文
和 再一次，我们只是
为那些想要停下来跟随小径的人放了很多文字
，这一切都陷入了
斯蒂芬和 你对现实主义工具主义的评论
我想
我想到的大部分是
所有这一切然后
在某种程度上在行动中得到支持所以
寻找不同的
矛盾或不同的复古
方法的想法
可能是一个案例 你想象
当有人考虑
在你知道的树林中走一条路，
或者你可以重新体现很多
这些东西，
或者也许在某种程度上，一切
都经历了某种体现，
嗯，当它是概念上的
体现只是发生在 一个更
概念化的空间
嗯，它不依赖于许多其他
类型的故事或
感受你的方式，
所以
当你
在一个实践领域发生的不同之处在于你已经
习惯了在那个领域 实践领域
，
那个化身变成了你游泳的水，
所以这可能
与这位
伟大的
院长有点相关 sm
对工具主义是的
是的到最后
没有或未完成
我们在这里有一点 & 和
我们和这里
嗯 一个关于 e 认知的简短说明
我们不会在这里深入讨论，但 4e 可以
参考 xiavio 和 van der
schiff 2018 年的论文是在
音乐教育学的背景下，这是一个
非常迷人的领域 4e 体现了
嵌入式嵌入式
扩展制定的
文化等等等 7e 11e 22e 所有
这些，然后是
来自我们 2021 年
应用主动推理研讨会的卡尔弗里斯滕的有趣引述
他说关于主动推理的一个关键
是它超越了预测
处理它超越了感知，它
强调或反映
了本世纪初
真正由四个 e 集中体现的务实转变，
以明确感知是
活跃的
并且你在说话 关于
与任何粒子个人或植物接触
的循环
因果关系 紫色循环因果关系 所有这一切
都非常简短 我们不打算
深入讨论这些细节，但这里有
一堆与非活动论文相关的工作，
只是一些其他背景
引文和其他工作，人们可能
想要研究
，对于溯源论文
，还有一个 稍微倾向于
一些东西，希望作者可以
为我们解开
唯名论与所有这些的作用和关系，
但是这里列出了作者以前的许多论文，
并且再次做了很多伟大的工作，所以
感谢你们现在
的旅程
我们可以进入两篇论文或
两者之间的空间
让我们初步
并列两篇论文我会放我们的视频将
是冰山一角所以院长
你是冰山一角
你想说什么 关于这两篇
论文的初步并列，
正如我所说的，我想
如果你真的退后一步
，通过与主动推理配对来意识到人们在做什么，
你说
我有我有一个特殊的类型
我想执行的情境分析
，在这样做的过程中，我
想尝试消除矛盾，或者我
想
制定整合
，如果你回到那个地方，
你的例子，所以你的超级你的
超级
你的头你的 主题是 sub uh
情境分析 你的例子
适合
你现在没有
犯错误，说我的
做事方式 自
地否定或转向其他方式
来看待该标
题下的所有事物 情境情境分析
尘埃落定 现在
有比较，他们没有
写在这里，他们已经准备
好了 推理以及
积极推理如何
围绕
注意力机制内的行为表现，并将
其开放给比注意力机制更可用的东西
心理理论的细节或规模友好的事情是否必然
与主动推理相结合，
或者当我到达的那一刻绑架的想法
实际上
否定了使用
仪器来扩展我的感官
窗口
的任何可能性，所以我们不会再次花费
花了很多时间
把其他东西拿出来，但是如果
人们想真正了解当您
将大约两张纸并排放置时，
您会发现很多
相似之处，
这是一项有趣的练习，
需要一段时间，
但是当您真正看到它们时 并排
纠缠在一起，有
很多编织正在进行，
谢谢院长斯蒂芬，
是的，我喜欢这个，嗯，
就像院长所说的那样，你
有这两篇论文，它几乎可以
看作是两座冰山，
他们的哲学是善良的
冷冻的，
给定的形状和形式，
下面有东西，上面有东西，
但中间也有水
，可能有
很多呃虾 有各种各样的
东西在四处游荡，所以
我认为在这个列表中，
你有一种现实主义的
器乐主义，它们是你的两座
冰山，对了，
我们希望它们既漂亮又锋利
，如果你砰砰作响，也许你会被撞到一点
关闭它们，然后好的统计数据
和模型比较
你知道
它们它们仍然存在，但
它们可能会影响多智能体的
信念交流哦，等等，我们
这里有一些流动的
东西作为集合的集合对不起
模型作为集合的
观点
或者紧身衣的观点，或者这些
观点来自于了解
随机复杂系统的方式
等等
它们是
不同类型的 um
方式，
并且开始变得更加灵活
和不稳定，
太棒了，所以我们进入非活动论文，
以便保持事情合理，并且
还有很多要讨论的内容
第二，我们在幻灯片上放了很多内容，
让您停下来欣赏
大部分内容都是从论文中复制和引用的
，因此这是
了解更多信息的参考点，
我们将
按照路线图的顺序进行介绍
论文所经历的一些关键部分，因此
在非活动论文的第一节中，
他们将首先
总结 vessier at all 的 2020 年关于
理解世界上其他人的论点，并
通过其他思想在这篇论文中提出 然后
汤姆是心智理论
他们总结
或捕捉了
通过其他心智思考的论点作为一个
前提 一个社会认知是不活跃的
和体现的 二是不活跃的和体现
的 社会行为者不能直接掌握
社会认知
三任何不能直接掌握的东西都
必须推断
ergo qed 结论 非主动和具
身的社会认知必须被推断 必须有关于
社会认知的推断
和作者 不活跃的论文
指出，通过前提二和三
ttom 加入了 tom 正统的
理解世界和其他
人归结为推断
和归因心理状态的能力，
这是通过其他思想进行思考的呃总结
，他们将提出质疑
在这个批判性的剖析中，这样一个
ttom 帐户确实使这种幸福的
婚姻与一个激进主义
他们会拉上是的任何人
或继续好吧他们会他们
会他们会拉出几个
不同的 这些前提
以及隐藏的假设可能是
这些前提的基础，例如
公理导致生成这样的
前提
p1 和 p2 之间的矛盾是
由 t2m 论证中的两个隐藏假设造成的
，所以在这里我们看到
上面的 p123
，然后隐藏假设一个
社会认知简化为
明确命题形式的信息
心理表征和归属
他们会这么说 他们有
这样的感觉 心理
表征
和隐藏的假设 社会
认知与
用于推理的概念和逻辑工具紧密相连，
例如
在出生时
，在随后的部分中，
他们将分析和澄清
前提一和二之间的矛盾
，
如果社会认知不存在这种张力 t 积极和
具体
化 真的是这样，还是一个
自相矛盾的主张
，即社会认知不能
被这样一个社会行为者直接掌握，
然后他们将从不活跃的角度批判性地评估
这些假设背后可能存在哪些问题
隐藏的假设以及
为什么 一个活动家拒绝这些隐藏的
假设
，因此拒绝上面列出的前提
，然后他们将
探索这些非代表性的
方法和
社会行动中的共建机制是什么
他们有一个马尔可夫
毯子我们已经在视觉上表示
之前在这里看到
了内部状态，外部状态
和 in 的中介
根据珍珠 1988 年的定义
，外部状态和外部状态是使内部和外部状态
有条件地独立的毯状状态
有时人们会更进一步描述
一个脆弱的毯状，其中毯状
状态 b
被划分为两种状态：
感性和活动状态
这两种状态是
由它们从
内部状态
统计依赖的角度传入的、感觉状态
和传出的统计依赖定义的
，它们可以解释为
从实体或事物到利基的动作或接口，
但我们将回到马尔可夫毯子
稍后，
是的，斯蒂芬继续努力，
只是回到
之前的幻灯片页面，
但与此相关的是，当它说
事情不能直接发生时，有
几件事可以直接
掌握，我
认为这是一个 有用的区别，因为
当我们想到嗯我们在
谈论抓地力和 握把或一把
钳子，我不能直接握住热
管
当人们在思考
某件事时，
你是否知道要抓住
一些明确命题的东西，
你知道我们还有其他类型的工具
可能会发挥作用，即使
我们考虑文字
，而将
所有这些东西归因于这些东西的行为可能
是与 每个级别的工具，
所以这里
有一个有趣的混合，
这取决于
冰山如何
在第二部分中融化得很好
，你可以在论文中阅读或
在这里暂停并捕捉它的许多方面
社会认知简化为心理
表征
，
它们的观点可以提炼为
理解他人是一个
熟练掌握共享的非明确
含义的问题，
并且可能具有一些
溯因
ding-ding-ding 和基于模型的推理，
所有这些都是特定于上下文的
可修改和动态的
，它们将在后面的段落中解开，其中
存在
着前两个前提之间的明显矛盾，
这真的
就像阿喀琉斯之踵 或者
他们将
在第二部分中针对
他们的逻辑的软弱点，他们将质疑第二
个假设，即社会
认知从出生就被硬连线
，因此虽然他们确实符合最高
职位
并且他们说 vessier 做
不像纯粹的天生观点那样持有本土主义者的立场，
因为他们确实关注文化如何获得的
发展和生态动态
他们确实
对入门包的获得提出了质疑
，他们也在本
节中进行了更多探索 一些不活跃的批评，
例如第 3 节中关于社会认知的硬连线观点
，批评了
他们认为突出的假设
通过其他思想思考内在的矛盾
他们将暗示另一种
关系哦你不喜欢那道菜
让我们试试
这道菜这将
是动力系统理论
或dst的一种方法他们写
dst正如我们将在 本节是一种
方法，用于了解和
生成关于构建其利基
的代理的社会文化位置实践的预测能力，
因为 dst 在其核心具有
有用的工具，例如出现
非线性和自发性等，
它使我们能够摆脱
预制的概念
因此，人们应该避免做出
本体论假设 本体论的假设
是关于
世界上的事物如何，
因此更多的是哲学家本体论
而不是计算机科学
知识管理 本体论
这类
本体论假设
由关于复杂的现实主义许可
系统基于
易于处理的模型，
因此仅仅因为模型如此
易于处理
并不意味着我们
有权进行本体论假设，
因为易于处理的模型
是学习
复杂行为的机会，只允许认知主张
让我们更接近 看一下
使它易于处理的声明，我们可以
通过如下静态关系来表示动态系统
，这是
他们的方程式一二和三，并带有
下面的标题
，他们正在使用这些非常
简单的类型，就像
动力系统的内核 理论是
理解
事物是如何广泛变化的函数
，它以几种
不同的方式表示
，就后继模型和
更多变化模型而言，
斯蒂芬
我认为这是一个非常
有用的
第三点 点，因为它也说明
了
这是一种建模方法，
让我们看看模型
在告诉我们什么，而不是模型
拟合
接近
嗯，如果你有定义的本体，你通常会知道最终会发生什么，你知道
你有
很多事情，所以
嗯
，这可能是一个关键
部分
，它连接
了很多事情如何
在主动推理方面进行桥接，以及它如何
能够 被夹在你之间，
你知道
那
是一种姿势，
它把双腿分开，
说
好吧，
我是在劈叉还是
双腿并拢，
所以
让我们找出而不是
你，专家告诉我
嗯
是的，
谢谢院长，是的，
是的，我只是想补充一下
斯蒂芬刚才所说的内容
，到目前为止，我真的而且我喜欢
这篇论文
，它是建构主义的文章，
尽管我认为
这让我
暂停了一分钟，因为我
相信 为了让
我们能够
做出决定，
是分裂还是分叉，它
实际上是一个分叉，而
不是必须从左到右，这需要
解构
，我认为这通常是事先被遗漏的
为了重建，
所以我不再与作者争论，
因为我认为他们
尊重自主权，
而且我认为他们做得非常出色
，可以说这种逻辑
其他作者采取的这种演绎路径
可能不一定适用于这里 因为
它会导致过多的混合，所以很好，
很好，你是你，你正在举起
实际上是左右的，
但你忽略了
添加和部分，它可能是一个叉子，
我可以从字面上拿起和
你能看到的唯一方法是，如果你可以
在重构和解构之前解构
并不意味着区分
已经存在的解构字面
意思是
作为一体性
我什么时候到达这一刻我有什么我还缺少什么拼图的部分
因为
我急于弄清楚我是
应该向左还是向右，
尤其是在总体情况下，尤其是在
那里，
是的，斯蒂芬，如果您想
在这里快速指出一下，谢谢只是添加到
那个嗯
那个情景
嗯，我
相信这就是你开始
意识到正在发生的事情的地方，所以科学
在很大程度上告诉我们发生了
什么，那是
什么，这是什么，这是什么，
但那是岔路口，或者你
知道 团队团队年龄交界处或
其他东西
最终有意识部分
位于哪里，并且在主动
推理中通常更
复杂
，与科学存在关于方法的
准确性
的模糊性以及
其他时候意识和
复杂性来自主动推理可以
同时具有 那些是的，很棒，
继续阅读本文的后半部分，
他们谈论了
很多我们许多人都喜欢的
复杂性，如此复杂性，复杂性，科学，
复杂性，理论带来了很多
伟大的
术语，概念，人们，方法，工具，
想法，一切
，他们谈论了很多关于自动策略
和这种递归性 所以在非活动论文中有
很多非常有创意的链接链接
，复杂性是
在第四节中以一种非常有价值的方式使用
它们将
在不活跃的动态环境
中进行主动推理，这就是
将主动推理作为一种有见地的
工具来了解和理解
文化共建背后的动态的地方
考虑到它不一定将
代理作为被动
代理一起是彼此状态的作者
，所以
有点类似于前面显示的不活跃的
数字，我们
在头上有齿轮
，然后就像
齿轮更分散 在图 2 中的身体和
头脑中，有更多的
经典
意义和基于模型的推理，其中
不同的社会行为者
都有这种推理解释，
非常像一个方向，如图所示
，箭头指向
中间， 在图 3 中，他们
根据此处标记内部状态的主动推理来描述图 2 中的社会行为
社会行动者
和外部国家是社会行动
者 1，所以这是从
社会行动者 2 的角度来看，
其中一揽子国家被
框架为社会文化意义，以及
基于模型的推理
，它为分发和制定的推理账户打开了大门
，
[音乐]
希望我们能更详细地介绍，
因为这是他们
支持他们积极的
工具主义将积极
推理应用到社会非活跃空间的地方
，然后他们写了一个
类似于科学实践的社会场景的描述，这
是通过错误描述来描述的，这
几乎是 就像
在特定环境下在实验室中发生的事情，甚至
对
在特定环境
中在实验室
中发生的事情有一定的看法
在地下室和
建筑物周围的世界中
，这也是 r 与一些黄色布朗伯格的研究有很好的联系
，他
对预期大脑的研究并不是一位
科学家，他也
从生态的角度关注不活跃的观点，
不仅一定是
社会的，而且社会是他们将要讨论
的表 1 中的一个重要案例
更多关于
与自然世界和
科学工具和构造相关
的细胞的一些分隔符和内容，我们肯定会在
随后的讨论中回到这里，所以只需查看
表一，
看看你
认为你会怎么想 画
它们会不会有点像曲线
看起来像字母 你会圈出
任何东西 你会画一些三角形
你会添加另一行 你会不会把
它变成张量 你还会在桌子上画什么
即使只有另一条双边
界线来强调 就像院长一样完美，
我想说的是，如果你
去看看这个问问自己为什么这些
超参数以及为什么
这些迟到 rals，
因为我认为这会给我
带来各种各样的
好处，它只是让我
在
乐趣上扭曲了
好吧，然后在我们进入第二篇论文之前得出结论，
我们已经表明，同时持有
激进主义和心理理论必然会
产生矛盾和
当我们批判性地
剖析汤姆所持有的两个
隐藏的假设时，这一点就很明显
了
社会不作为
和递归以及随着
时间的推移展开 社会
不作为的推出
，他们认为动力系统
理论
和主动推理
作为一种动力系统
建模
具有前景，
并且是一种合适的补充工具，
可以将社会理解视为
广义
同步以某种方式保持，
因此 p  aper，
它现在将
与绑架纸配对，所以
在我们进入绑架之前先
吸一口气是的，斯蒂芬
深吸一口气，嗯，最后
一句话是关于它如何可以成为
几乎一座桥梁，它们是
动力系统理论的补充使用
并且有点填补了一个空白，他们有点
填补了这个空白，在某种程度上我认为当
我们谈论绑架文件时，一些
没有填补的空白
我知道我们并不是想在
这里谈论填补空白，但是 假设你正在
填补空白，
绑架
可能也会感觉到，所以你知道
主动推理之美的美妙之处
，贝叶斯方法
是许多不同的
尺度和模式，并且可以
加权和混合，让你
潜在地
感受到什么 做对了，
这并不意味着一个人排除了另一个
真棒
好的
相互绑架
我们迟钝
了 这篇论文以一个相对
简短且非常简洁的
介绍开始，介绍
了
我们之前描述的论文的一些关键点 r 他们的目标是
他们对后来的一些 cs pierce 的这种自然主义渲染感兴趣，
例如 1903 年后或 1905 年后
大部分未发表的作品
，解开我们在上下文部分中介绍的溯因推理的符号和逻辑概念，
他们的目标是
绑架的生物模型
将
穿针引线 编织织物
保持有机体的功能完整性
生物存在的进化必要性
并
与现代神经科学兼容
他们专注于我们的忠诚和
联盟 前面谈到过
，他们还将在
介绍中介绍马尔可夫毯概念
，这将是一个很好的并列点，
可以添加更多
细节，比如如果它是一个前沿，一个接触
前沿，具有主动推理与社会
不作为和绑架，
那么这些 就像
界面前面的热点或接触点，可以
真正放大，好吧
这两个模型中是否使用了内部状态，
这就是主动推理
本体具有巨大价值的地方，因为
即使人们说
不同的语言或者我们有一个
计算机程序，
当我们可以链接和主动地联系时，一个方程、一首诗和一篇科学论文
使用主动推理本体或主动注释
我们获得的能力不仅仅是说好
我们都指向月亮
是你的手指我的手指还是我们
指向同一个手指因为它
很远所以可能有点
咬断了，从我的角度来看，你的光线错过了
月亮
，等等，我们实际上可以
下来，而不是
在手术台上流血，
而是暂时固定下来，找到
一个吸引子，帮助我们真正进入
那个十字路口，而不是 而不是
仅仅用共振点来击打和奔跑，
是的，
我只是总结一下，我们
可以更好地进行情境分析，因为
我们现在实际上是
有一种方法可以将一些
共同的
东西放在
一起，这就是我想添加到你刚才所说的内容中的所有内容，
并且只是在上面添加一个，
是的，对不起，但是嗯
，可能
会有不同，所以
你知道喜欢
可能对很多术语有这样的理解
本体论的
理解，并
说通常的问题是，如果有
一些东西没有
对齐
但没有被注意到或被刷过，说
好的，这是不同的，好的，这里有一个
本体的变化，
有一个 有一种
方法可以
像我们通过主动推理一样
易于处理，这是一种易于处理的方式，因为
否则
在这个空间中漂浮着太多本体论的东西，
这就是它的美丽
，以至于在认知上
不可能找到你的东西 需要看
下一节
再看一遍这两个灯
共照明共构建
没有两个灯可以物理重叠
所以必须有视差引起 通过这
两个光影和各种
效果，也许它不是相同的
波长，也许你在
四处走动，不同的侧面有
不同的照明
该部分正在根据绑架的光进行主动推断
这
是非常
迷人的部分，
因为它们 将采用在 1800 年代后期和 1900 年代初期开发的
几乎是
准算法
但肯定是
预计算
框架，
并开始
接口并
了解它与主动推理的关系，
以便我们可以强调更多内容，我们
期待在
如果你想
阅读所有这些或阅读论文，请暂停它，
但他们专注于后期模式
是的，请院长我想说的
是，如果你真的
低头看底部的子弹
照明实际上是在尝试
钱包谈论它也许我
不知道他是否真的有
形式主义来支持这一点，
但主动推理现在确实在
谈论
关于我们现在可以
在两个
限制条件下看到的那种能量水平，那个
参数化回到副握把
的想法
谢谢你，所以这里只有一些引人入胜的引述，
所以
在科学绑架中 可以比作
发现假设的逻辑
，正如我们之前讨论的那样，它具有
生成的创造性元素，然后是
贝叶斯模型选择贝叶斯模型
简化
等次要选择组件，它们甚至添加了一个警告性的
评论，即不会发生完全
同化皮尔逊绑架
对 ibe 来说，
这是
对二冲程发动机一半的最佳解释的推论，通常
人们会使用溯因推理来指代
给定集合的概率推理，
例如著作中其他地方的溯因推理，
后来的架构中
那些在 1903 年之后
但
根据 对专家来说，研究最少
的是从观察到
令人惊讶的 e 因子开始的 发泄
观察惊讶
并通过一个有条件的
大前提再次以一种共同的情绪结束一种情绪，
这种情绪被称为调查员，
它就像它拥有并且就在其中
，那就是应该做一些至关重要的
事情
实用主义 不作为
最初引起的政策选择 通过好奇心
不确定性减少熵
，导致提出一个
语义问题，并且
对
调查情绪和其他情绪
有更多
讨论 我认为也许可以
在接下来的几个直播中更多地戏弄这一点的重要性，
真棒
他们将继续这个
研究经济的问题，
所以
他们形成了三个辩论课程，
真正指定了与主动推理的联系领域
和
他们建议的绑架形成一个最初的三人组
或三人组
，这将是明星 t 形成
主动推理和溯因推理之间的忠诚
首先
是非退化三元关系的存在，
然后是利用
溯因推理的主要原则
b 和第三虚拟条件
表述
有一些逻辑技术
细节，但这
就是流的目的
在第 a 点
，您可以暂停并阅读
他们将突出马尔可夫
毯子概念的文本，
或者更确切地说，
他们将现实主义
解释为第一和毯子，
并
认为马尔可夫毯子再次
以现实主义的第一和毯子意义实施，
具有明显的穿透力
不可约的三元形式
关注边界，作为
外部内部状态之间的中介，
因此符号学中出现的
第三性
还有很多要说的，但是
如果你们中的任何一个想在 b 中的 OK 上多加一点，
他们将继续
讲一些推理的指导原则
，具体讨论ab 归纳
在指导推理中的作用
什么是主动推理的主要原则
那么
在这里，他们将
根据自由能变分或
预期作为边界惊喜来描述主动推理的一些技术细节
，然后他们会将其与
一些主要的 刺穿的来源和
生物符号学的讨论，这
也与
我们关于
表征和意义等的许多讨论相关联
，
它甚至更深入或更深入
地讨论了
协同论
以及这个
普遍思想的问题
在某些方面是力量老化普遍
认知泛认知动力学
分布式认知系统
物质是冯席勒的有效思维
然后他们将争论
原始毯子及其
在三元关系方面的构造
皮尔逊三元符号对象解释蚂蚁
导致未探索
将这些更广泛的
定性线程中的一些结合在一起的语义可能性 n
使用潜在动力系统
理论定量贝叶斯方法的符号学分析以及
主动推理带来的所有其他东西，
以及要实现的工具包
，看看
它们也在 c 中，如果我可以的话，将解开符号命题的一些
非常
有趣但微妙的逻辑
构造元素
称它为
在进一步讨论中更多地讨论它，
但他们将探索
条款或断言和
保证之间逻辑关系的不同框架以及所有这些修辞
如何与
现实主义
绑架
和
皮尔斯的现实主义版本有关，因为
可能是什么可以成为现实
是的，有些事情是可能的，
但不能成为现实，然后
我们将什么用于相邻或
可实现的
可能性
，
我们可能想在哪里使用它，以及什么
会打破这种对称性在哪里是
实用主义好什么是有用的
考虑将是
可能发生的所有可能的空间，没有
其他和 n 不要对
我们没有考虑但确实发生的相邻可能性感到惊讶
，然后
花一点额外的想法或一些
额外的计算机资源来考虑
不可能发生
但我们不想要的可能性也许还不错 迷失在不可能发生
的可能性的潜在指数空间中
，最终失去我们
对可能发生的可能性的关注和关注，
这就是皮尔斯所描述
的真正可能性
，实用主义的立场
和情绪
也通过政策
选择和 积极
推论
中的实用主义，他们说，在
巴黎灾难公式中信仰的实用主义含义
是，在一个人
能够采取行动
并且在那里有很多共鸣的地方，
斯蒂芬
是的，我认为这也说明
了需要有
我们谈论规模友好或关卡，
或者
你知道某种结构可以
实现
这一点，因为
你知道积极影响可以如此 rt
一直向下并
带入细胞水平，因为这里有很多
看待它
的方式，有一种感觉，好吧，我们
正在研究
这些嗯
，嗯，一个能指的想法，
但我们通过主动推理知道这
不是它 相信我们有
信号进来，这些信号会被处理
和聚合，
所以有一种尺度，在这个尺度上
，你有你有形态发生的结构，
也许可以达到
一个尺度，
使停车标志有意义
，被
解释为它的 自己的
能指，所以我认为这可能是
这里的不积极分子之间会发生这种紧张
关系的地方，以及
可能发生这种情况的地方，但
我很可能会说，某些
规模的
某些结构
和某些现实主义
的事情发生方式
就像 这
是可行的，
很好，只是院长，然后我们将
快速完成剩下的工作，让我在
这里真的很快，我认为尤其是在 b
中，直到较小的程度和 c
的公共汽车 我们如何将思考刺穿
到主动推理领域
是建立在一个假设之上的，那
就是继续我们的持续
存在，我们持续的
现实，嗯，
意味着我们正在
通过世界上的工具积累更多的经验，世界上的规则 世界
和池子，池子我指的
是斯蒂芬刚刚指出的那些聚合，
谢谢你提出
这个问题，因为这让我想把
聚合写下来，作为
两个密度实现的密度故事，
所以我不
知道你
只说一切都是真实的，
然后它下面的所有例子
也是真实的，因为即使是皮尔斯自己也
说过，这个现实的一个方面是
我们永远
无法描述为非现实以外的任何东西，
即使我们从根本上使用 它
是如何
使这些密度形成的，我
知道这听起来很糟糕，
我很抱歉，但它是 实际上，我们
必须考虑的事情，
谢谢
他们然后将
翻转脚本或至少语法
并根据
主动推理
来谈论绑架，这是他们开始
承认具有生成绑架的二冲程发动机
和 选择性
诱拐
，然后他们将把它
与主动推理的一些本体联系起来
，比如将
选择性诱拐
视为一个采样
过程，
并理解生成性
诱拐适用于何处，
因此继续
从主动推理的角度看待诱拐
我们甚至可以将其操作化为
从主动推理本体的角度构建或查看溯因，
而不是我们
自选
将主动推理解释为
某些
概念，我们不一定
代表一个
我们不能说英语的概念，但是 我们可以
使用英语单词
，因此类似地，我们不必
为主动 infe 说话
虽然我是最后一个说那些
应该或不应该做什么的人，
但可以
使用主动推理本体，
然后它有点像一个两步
清单，
是
核心补充或推理本体行为中的术语
包含的
部分是否
以务实的方式使用，
在那种多尺度背景下的情况下有意义
，这实际上是一个两步过程
，询问我们是否
使用主动推理而不是
我们是否在为 像倡导者或
像销售人员一样进行主动推理
，他们将
在 fap 框架的意义
上重述案例，并使用术语
，他们将强调
内部状态
与外部状态的关系 状态通过
毯子进行调解
，然后他们通过这个三段论
，他们重组和重申他们
的溯因主动推理的定性模式
，他们描述了这个
动作认知感知
循环
，其中
一个surp 重新体验任何传入的
感官信息
，然后
他们不仅将其纳入贝叶斯生成模型的背景
下对它的被动甚至主动解释，
而是在他们继续并带来
的调查者的那种情绪中展开的东西
嗯
，研究经济的重要突破性思想，
所以我们希望与作者再次讨论
这个问题，嗯，它与皮尔斯的
科学
理论
有关 在效用
和成本之间
，具体而言，这将
与这种社会
制定的实用主义意义上
的
研究有关
获得最多的信息
，研究人员可以进行哪些实验
来减少他们的不确定性
不是为了验证他们知道的
东西，不仅仅是为了伪造
他们知道会被伪造的东西，而是
要存在于这个最佳的实验
空间中
，然后刺穿，然后
作者将自然化语境化
带来社会 认知领域
通过很好地询问金钱时间和
精力是如何发生的，因为最佳
实验是培养的，并且它使用
能量它使用试剂所以也许通过
这种方式我们可以说皮尔斯
是主要资助机构的第一批现代项目经理之一，但是 不，
他不是，他们更多地讨论了这种
研究经济，
他们在本节中描述
了 pierce 如何
促进几种
价值或美德或品质，这些价值或美德或品质
是科学假设经济的特征
，
复杂性就像一个降低风险的
广度 统一
和谨慎
是
通过巧妙地打破边际收益来避免边际收益递减的经济品质 将问题
分解为一系列
可以在合理的投资限制下回答的小问题
我会让你
公平地说
我只是为了公平而阅读它，正如
本文开头所简要说明的那样，
没有
对 fep 及其
成分（如马尔可夫毯）的工具主义解释，
但这是本文中的一个脚注，但我们的
信念 对于 fep 的更好的词和
现实主义凭据之一，它
源于实用主义实用主义的乐观主义，或者
更确切地说，它的艾米利亚主义行为关于
从进化进化有用过程之间的联盟中获得的收益，
如果这种实用主义的现实主义方法
不满意，则有助于最大限度地提高生存率
寻找一些坚定的形而上学
标准的人的味道让一千朵
鲜花bl 嗯，我认为这很吸引人
的是
，持有现实主义的想法
是一个非常容易辩护的立场
，但即使在上一张幻灯片
中，首先谈到的事情之一是
没有
直接或至少没有直接说出来 那些引述
是
，最佳位置是一些
剥削或经济
或简单的元素，或者或有人在我之前做过这件事
是
，往往需要
更长时间的捷径和探索有更多的
试验和错误，
但也不会让你经常
过度拟合
到一个特定的结果，
所以
嗯
，这就是现实
，再说一次，我不会，我不会
拒绝声称这出戏有一个非常
真实的
部分，
至少有两个
在这个
um 中来回播放，
所以
我是 不仅事实上，我完全同意
这些作者的观点，就像我完全
同意其他作者
关于共建的想法一样，所以我
不知道
你是你，你是
你，你一定会感到困惑，如果 你
可以说是，是，是的，
史蒂文是的，有点补充那里所说
的内容，
实施或
利用的想法肯定被提及
，在科学
中，
实验是一种获取知识的方式，
但有探索片和
我会争辩说，
你不能
在
客观领域内进行探索本身，必须
像爱因斯坦用他的智力游戏所做的那样，进入表演性主观进入主观阈限的旅程，
而你创造了这些
心理的呃以某种方式构建
今天正在发生的一些事情是它的
混合，然后将其带回来
并用任何东西进行建模，
所以我认为有一个我的意思是建模很
有趣，因为
它是呃它可以在那个
旅程中出现 一点点也好，
所以这
可能是
实验无法做到的事情
这里是一个老笑话人 a
说 a
和 ref 的摘要 eree 说你是对的
b 说 b 裁判说你是对的
，而 c 说好 a 和 b 不可能是
对的，裁判说你知道
你是对
的，对于喜欢这样的人来说，这有点快速幽默
类型
嗯，然后他们有一个结论部分
，
我们有很多问题和要点要
提出，还有很多联系要
带回这里的很多归化，
比如莱文
工作中的领域，他们甚至把它带到
扁虫的再生能力上，所以
从
扁平蠕虫到室友
，这就是我们今天要去的地方
，然后我们还为第一个点保存
了马尔可夫
毯概念的一些并列，特别
是科学的社会和积极成分，
这些成分非常重要，并且
majeed已经给这些带来了
以前的讨论是
与绑架论文的一个很好的联系点，
而社会不活跃的论文
马尔可夫毯子代表了一个非常
受限制的甚至是技术
接触的前沿，这将提供很多
讨论 离子在第一个点中
，这就是
我们关闭点零的地方
，嗯
，院长和史蒂文再次做了很多出色的基础工作和背包包装，所以
你现在还有什么想补充
的，或者
你想讨论的任何问题 在 dot one 是
dean 然后 stephen 如果你想要 daniel
出色的工作，我们刚刚
从通常的
单一纸质直播流中完成了 3 个数量级，
我们仍然在两个小时内完成了它，所以你就是
你 为此而受到称赞，
其次，我只是想
为
dot
提供一点小费 并
构建您必须查看两个
产品的过程中的一个示例是
我如何制造汽车
并在产品中加工
什么是
分支
点或实际用具是什么
，所以如果您敞开
心扉 沿着那个倒置
continuum
它开辟了各种可能性
，将事物带到一个
不一定会发生冲突的地方
意见
既是产品和过程，又是过程和
产品
，同时
是抓手和抓手也许他们会也许他们
会给他们一些想法，
这几乎就像实用主义者看到了
岔路口并使用它
，也许你 通过一种方式使用叉子
，也许你确实拿起它也许
你通过
为其他将在那里用餐的人完成餐桌设置
来使用它，所以有很多使用方法，
因为使用是
社会制定的，可溯源的
上下文等，
然后再一次 岔路
口是对话发生的地方
，在我们的现场或大本营
，我们可以想象岔路口和
道路将遇到
斯蒂芬耶，接下来是在
如果你
认识的人在一段旅程中可能会沿着
其中一个岔口走下去，也许它会到
湖边，我们需要进去弄湿
一点 科学
溯因或某种更
科学的有界
模型规则是否可以通过
实验和仪器
来证实是否可以？
我想知道这
是您可能想要考虑的事情
，我们如何才能
提供
某种明确的
旅程选择，以便他们可以
稍微离开，而不会
陷入您知道的流沙或
溺水深水中
对 所以我们想要进行导航，
但我认为这是给定的
一些我认为有
waze 出口以及 坡道所以
谢谢
谢谢各位
谢谢谢谢
这是巨大的我真的很感谢
你所有的帮助
美好的时光看到你在娃娃一个
你